[MUSIC PLAYING]
KARISHMA SHAH: Today I'd
like to say, not only
should you all be here,
but the technology industry
needs the insights,
perspectives,
and ideas of females.
And you all must be here.
TINA LEE: I'm a strong,
ambitious woman.
Is there anyone
else here like that?
Yeah.
Good, because I need your help.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
--to increase
the visibility of these
women and to come together
as a community.
SUSAN KOGER: You have
to take care of yourself
so that you're a better team
member, you're a better boss,
you're a better family member.
KATHY PHAM: Some of these
things seem impossible.
But we just believe
that we can do it.
OBI FELTEN: Bravery
is about taking action
in spite of your fears.
MELODY MCCLOSKEY: Trying
it and falling on my face
and failing in
front of everyone,
that's not as bad as not doing
it and having someone else
do it.
BRI JAMES: We try to celebrate
kind of the little wins
along the way.
Because it's those nuggets
that, when you're in that panic,
kind of carry you through.
RUTH PORAT: How do we
make the organization
that we're part of better as
a result of us being there?
MELINDA BRIANA EPLER: Here we
are at the center of innovation
in Silicon Valley.
We have to change
it here and now.
MIMI FOX MELTON: It is vital
that you as an individual
get involved.
POORNIMA VIJAYASHANKER: So
realize that when you speak,
opportunities emerge.
And you're making a difference.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
LINDSAY JEAN THOMSON:
What story will you tell?
And who will you
inspire with your words
and with your actions?
AREZOO RIAHI: While
challenges are global,
so is the power of
mentorship and our network.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
And we want to continue
to support you with as much
fuel, since to me, all of you
are fire starters.
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR:
You are amazing.
You are a role model.
You are an inspiration.
You're a bridge to a lot of
people to a better tomorrow.